related but unrelated what about I'll
say girls women however you want to
describe them the ones that get pregnant
on purpose to keep the man
yeah so I I I've been waiting to try to
get my voice heard here
it does happen I know women that have
done it
I know men that have done that of course
yeah but but yeah
purposely coming inside a girl yeah to
get her pregnant so that she'll stay
with her wow
but a woman can still get rid of it the
man doesn't have a choice yeah but the
man can pressure them into keeping you
don't have to yeah
but you still literally don't have to
all right guys let her let her finish
yeah so this is this is a big thing and
um women will do it on purpose it
doesn't matter what age you are what
background they think that's the way to
keep a man to retain a relationship to
perhaps even force a man into marriage
for some years that may not even last
and where you were talking about the
parents staying together
if that's what happens then then man
feels they've got no other choice but to
okay I've got married this girl she's
pregnant how long is that going to last
because they're then forced into the
situation they actually don't want to
live together
but then they understand the
responsibility of co-parenting you know
if if the woman has done that and the
and their father has tried and the right
gonna marry you or I'm going to move him
with you we're having a child together I
don't like what you've done you know you
forced me into it but I'm gonna try
living with each other
for the sake of the children where you
said the children have to stay together
was he dating her first was he like
dating her was it uh suggestion that
there was
um
one of I say one of the gyms that I used
to go to
um
the the girl got pregnant on for purpose
thinking that would enhance a
relationship force them into marriage
and being able to keep the relationship
she was like dating him yeah they were
dating and
um they split up and all I can say is
you know there are exceptions uh the
most amazing father ever he took up his
responsibilities he absolutely adores
his son but he was forced into that
situation but all that did is you know
they end up breaking up did they did
they get married and then separate or no
they just agreed that they couldn't make
it work that they weren't interested in
each other they just decided to raise
his child but like separately they were
raising the child separately she forced
him into situation to try and retain the
relationship yeah that's an exception I
think I think the main the main thing
the main point here is like taking
accountability of your purposeful
actions so what happened to the
relationship like what happened to the
relationship after like she like
basically baby trapped him like
did they decide to like Force themselves
to live together
exactly no no no none of that she forced
the situation she forced the situation
which obviously he was not happy about
but despite the situation and then
breaking up he stepped up as the one of
the most responsible amazing fathers
that he could ever meet whilst living
separately though yeah yes okay
most of my words like most like the
majority of men yeah like we think
logically right and of course we go out
to cover the basis I want to make sure
that my child can eat I want to make
sure that my child has a roof over there
and I want to make sure that my child is
an education the other Comfort bits we
may not all be so good at that but I'll
say that in no such situation they're
speaking to all
women who are thinking of doing this
right now to trap a man that is the best
way to terminate your relationship
because that guy right there he may have
he may with patience he may have he may
have loved you for life right yeah but
trapping a man is just it's almost the
most certain surest way to create an
enemy of like that guy will hate hates
hates her existence but loves his child
I'm saying so it's a thing where like
that's that's it's it's an unproductive
strategy of getting love and it doesn't
work because it's not sustainable
because you haven't built that
foundation and all of a sudden you're in
a really high pressure situation where
you're like oh my God
that's a horrible horrible thing you
know what it is that's that's I'm really
conflicted on that because I don't
really like rewarding bad behavior but
at the same time like I think it's about
the kids first I don't know because you
know what it is men are more accountable
for their actions so imagine that
situation is going to think do you know
what I'm not in her so
oh God I look after the kids you know
what I mean
I did it
there's also the point I mean I mean I'm
talking about this as a woman and I'm
I'm almost siding with a man talking
about this woman because I know people
that have done this where the woman on
purpose
will miss taking her pill and they're
you know whatever else she's doing she
will make the situation so it actually
happens how do you like did they tell
you this or how do you know they did it
well if we're talking about my um the
guy I know from the gym I don't know
what happened there but I do my most
recent ex
um you know we kept going back you know
on off on off and in between one of the
times where he end up dating someone
else then we got back together she
actually did that
she claimed she was taking her pill and
there was all these sorts of things
um she tried to trap him
yeah she stopped She yeah this is this
is my ex
um yeah she tried to chat for him and
she fell pregnant and um
he and I ended up getting back together
again for a millionth time
um and then
sadly which I would never wish on any
man or any woman
um
she missed she miscarried but
um things I I don't I can't say I'm not
going to go into medical things why
things happen but I do know that she was
my last say taking uh I don't know what
my last time you do she she was taking
drugs am I allowed to say oh God I don't
know what I can say you can talk about
drugs
she she was taking a certain type of
drug
um
and I can only guess I can't say the
deaf enough but I I could say that what
she was taking and her lifestyle and the
alcohol and the things that she was
doing may have this is May but
necessarily contributed to that stress
on the body will induce her and abortion
I mean there's a there's a reason Drake
puts hot sauce in his condom come on
like there's a reason like girls do that
yeah I didn't know you guys do you think
that a girl that lies to a man about
being on the pill
um and gets pregnant should be pursued
for fraud
it's disgusting it's disgusting
let's say let's say it could be proven
like she admitted I told him I was
taking birth control
and pretends to wear a condom and he's
not same thing that is essay so if you
pretend to take the phone you're not as
I say yeah you'll have his own name but
it's definitely need I think again uh
why did I decide to agree once with
pearl because now I seem to agree with
it on a lot I do think that's something
turning you no you're not turning me I
think we're just finding common ground
because there's gray areas in the world
as you know but I do think that there's
a lot of um things that in the
relationship between women and men where
women are actually favored and they do
then kind of get away with taking with
not taking accountability for certain
stuff so that is why I would then just
say from the moment go
pick somebody that will be a good father
to your children and a good man to you
and that doesn't mean he needs to be
with you that's all you need to do in
fact forget about the good man just let
him be a good father that's all you need
because that kid forget about your
relationship with him don't how would
the fraud thing work like just like
thinking out like uh and it makes sense
but is it like would the fraud payments
cancel out
yeah and then what would happen with the
baby
um I would guess the only way you could
prove it is a text if she told someone
yeah
I don't that's I would guess
um it's quite common but then I just
come to control it you said visually
recording her like what visually
recording you're taking yeah I have no
idea
a girl admitted it on national TV she
asked if she asked you was at a talk
show a couple years ago and she asked
the host if she should I think it was
one Wendy Williams maybe or maybe a
different host um and she basically
asked them if she would she could stop
taking the pill she she her husband
doesn't want more kids she does should
she stop taking the pill and just get
pregnant and literally they told her yes
wow if the if the mind's on showing like
I don't know like if you're that unsure
that your wife is going to do that he
didn't want any more kids and like I
don't know I don't know the situation
but yeah but yeah he either gets a
vasectomy or he just starts wearing
condoms if you were that unsure
I don't think most men expect their wife
to death
he's watching TV he's like what if
you're managing that kind of it's
entrapment why are you there like if
you're like you you have an idea she
could do this so I'm gonna get the snip
or I think I'm like bro like why are you
with this stuff you shouldn't have to
think like that but you know what I
think on this subject yeah talking as a
guy I think there's there's also needs
to be
um I guess more accountability from from
from from both sides because I follow a
lot of This falls on the women 100
um because you know if you don't if you
don't want to take but if you don't want
to take pills then what you do I mean
like most guys would not go through the
same equivalent and there are those
options so I feel like it's about
balancing that in a way because yes I do
agree if you say on the pill and you
don't take the pill even the pill itself
is 100 so I mean so I think it's a bit
foolish to rely on the Pearl on a pill
and with the expectation that you will
never have a child yeah and this just
opens up the the idea should men have to
kind of do something about contraception
other than just like wearing under them
because it's all the responsibilities on
the woman when women could have
temporary vasectomies
in terms of birth control
then have the guys you sleep with wear
condoms yeah but condoms don't always
work okay then get a plan B yeah but why
does that have to always fall on me like
why does it always have to be my body
because we have the freedom it comes
with responsibility but men could also
just get a temporary vasectomy and it's
completely reversed celibacy is
me taking loads of forms of birth
control I could gain weight I could be
emotional I could feel just like okay
you could be celibate come on celibacy
is 100 yeah so we also have the option
of abortion we're the ones that put them
on child support keep your pants locked
men and women keep your pants locked put
a padlock this is my set been my saying
for a year
for a year or two now to anybody who
asked me put a padlock on your pants
as well you could only just have sex
with people you are okay having a child
with yeah yeah
like but that temporary vasectomy I mean
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible